you also write
when it comes to human minds variation
is the norm
and what we call quote human nature is
really
many human natures again
many questions i can ask here but maybe
an interesting one to ask is um i often
hear
you know we often hear this idea of be
yourself
is this possible to be yourself is it a
good idea to strive to be yourself is it
does that even have any meaning it's a
very western question
first of all because which self are you
talking about
you don't have one self there is no self
that's in essence of you
you have multiple selves actually there
is research
on this um you know to quote um
the great social psychologist hazel
marcus you're never
you cannot be a self by yourself you
you know you and so different contexts
pull for or or draw on different
features of yours of who you are or what
your what you believe what you feel
what your actions are um
a different context you know we'll put
certain things or make
more some features be more in the
foreground and and some
in the background it takes us back right
to our discussion earlier about
um stalin and hitler and so on the thing
that i would
caution in addition to the fact that
there is no single self
you know that you have multiple selves
who you can be
um and you can certainly choose the
situations that you put yourself
in to some extent not everybody has
complete choice but everybody has a
little bit of choice and
i think i said this to you before that
one of the pieces of advice that we gave
sophia you know when she went
our daughter when she was going off to
college was
um try to spend time around people
choose relationships that allow you to
be your best self
we should have said your best selves but
um
you know the pool of cells given the
environment
uh yeah but i i get the one thing i do
want to say is that
um the risk of saying be yourself just
be yourself
is that um that can be used as an excuse
well this is just the way that i am
i'm just like this and um that
i i think should be tremendously
resistant
so that's one that's the that's for the
excuse side but
you know i'm really self-critical often
i'm full of doubt
and people often tell me just don't
worry about it just be yourself
man and it's the thing is
uh it almost it's not from an
engineering perspective does not seem
like actionable advice
because uh i guess constantly worrying
about
who what are the right
words to say to express how i'm feeling
is i guess my self
there's there's a kind of line i guess
that this might be a western idea but
something that feels genuine and
something that feels not genuine
and i'm not sure what that means because
i would like to be
fully genuine and fully open but i'm
also
aware like this morning i was like very
like silly and giddy like
this is just being funny and relaxed and
light like there's nothing
that could um bother me in the world i
was just smiling and happy
and i remember last night was just
feeling like very grumpy
like uh like stuff was bothering me
like certain things were bothering me
and like though what are those are those
are different selves
like what who am i in that and what do i
do because
if you know if you take twitter as an
example if i actually send a tweet
last night and i tweet this morning it's
going to be very two different people
tweeting that and i don't know what to
do with that because one does
seem to be more me than the other
but that's maybe because there's a
narrative a story that i'm trying
there's something i'm striving to be
like the
ultimate human that i might become i
have maybe a vision of that and i'm
trying to become that
it it does seem like there's a lot of
different minds in there
and they're all like like having a
discussion
and a battle for who's gonna win i
suppose you could think of it that way
but there's another way to think of it
i think and that is that um maybe the
more buddhist way to think of it
right or more contemplative way to think
about it which is not that you have
multiple
personalities inside your head but you
have
your brain has this um
amazing capacity it
it has a population of
experiences that you've had that it can
regenerate reconstitute and it can even
take bits and pieces of those
experiences
and combine them into something new um
and it's often doing this to predict
what's going to happen next
and to plan your actions but it's also
happening this also happens just
um that's what mind wandering is or just
internal thought and
and so on that's it's the same mechanism
really and so
a lot of times we hear the saying you
know just
think if you think differently you'll
feel differently
but your brain is having a conversation
continually with your body
and your body your brain's you know
trying to control your body
well trying your brain is controlling
your body your body is sending
information back to the brain
and in part the information that your
body sends back to your brain
just like the information coming from
the world
initiates the next volley of predictions
or simulations
so in some ways you could also say
the way that you feel your i think we
talked before about
affective feeling or mood coming from
the sensations of body budgeting
you know influences
what you think and
as much as so feelings influence thought
as much as
thought influence feeling and maybe more
but just
the whole thing doesn't seem stable well
it's a dynamic system
mr engineer yeah right it's a dynamic
it's a dynamical system right non-linear
dynamical system
in a re and i think that's i'm actually
writing a paper with a bunch of
engineers about
about this actually but um i i mean
other people have talked about the brain
as a dynamical system before but
you know the real tricky bit is trying
to figure out how do you get mental
features out of that system
like it's one thing to figure out how
you get a motor movement out of that
system it's another thing to figure out
how you get a mental feature
like a feeling of being loved or a
feeling of being worthwhile or a feeling
of you know just basically feeling like
[ __ ] how do you get a feeling
a mental mental features out of that
system
um so what i would say is that
you aren't the buddhist thing to say is
that you're not one person and you're
not many people
you are um
you are the sum of your experiences and
who you are in any given moment
meaning what your actions will be is
influenced by the state of your body and
the state of the world that you've put
yourself in
and you can change either of those
things one is a little easier to change
than the other right you can
change your environment by literally
getting up and moving
or you can change it by paying attention
to some things differently and
letting other some features um come to
the fore and other features
be backgrounded like i'm looking around
your place oh no
and i see not something you should do no
i'm not but i'm going to say one thing
yeah no green plants
no green plants because green plants
mean a home and i want this to be
temporary
fair fair but what's what's what goes to
your mind when you see no green plants
no i'm just making the point that um
what if you again you know
not everybody has control over their
environment
some people don't have control over the
noise or the temperature
or you know any of those things but
everybody has a little bit of control
and you can place things in your
environment
photographs plants
anything that's meaningful to you and
use it as a shift of environment when
you need it
yes you can also do things to change the
conditions of your body when you
exercise every day
you're making an investment in your body
actually you're making an investment in
your brain too it makes you
even though it's unpleasant and you know
if there's a cost to it if you replenish
if you
invest and you make up that you make a
deposit and you
make up that what you've spent you're
basically making an investment
in making it easier for your brain to
control
your body in the future so you can make
sure you're hydrated
drink water you don't have to bite drink
bottled water you can drink water from
the tap
this is in most places maybe not you
know maybe not everywhere but
but most places in the developed world
um you can try to get enough sleep
not everybody has that luxury but
everybody can do something
to make their you know body budgets a
little more solvent
and that will also make it
more likely that certain thoughts will
emerge from that prediction
machine is that that's the control you
do have it's
uh yeah being able to control the
environment that's really well put
you